[Musica]
ma vi siete mai chiesti perché le donne
hanno la cellulite gli uomini no
purtroppo ahimè non è solo una questione
di fattore c in realtà dipende tutto
dall'architettura della pelle negli
uomini la parte grassa sprofonda
perpendicolarmente quindi non si vede
nelle donne invece hai mai viene a galla
e si vede quante volte vi è capitato di
dire a pelle quella persona non mi piace
oppure
appella e questa situazione non è molto
interessante e sapete perché accade
questo
perché a livello embrionale
lo stesso foglietto germinativo che
genera la pelle genera anche il sistema
nervoso centrale con questo vi voglio
introdurre a quello che è una storia la
narrazione sostanzialmente di di un
grande amore di una grande passione nei
confronti di questo segmento di questo
organo
invisibile meraviglioso che ci racchiude
much racchiude o farà qualcos'altro ma
per raccontarvi questa esperienza b vi
chiedo di salire nella macchina del
tempo e di fare un salto indietro di 40
anni quando sono nata perché se nasci
con un dna meticcio incomincia a farti
delle domande un pochino strane e devi
iniziare a decidere se
avvicinarti a una delle due indole che
ti sono state concesse a uno dei due
ingredienti che ti sono stati
sostanzialmente iniettati che dovevo
scegliere tra la componente prettamente
scientifica medicale quella di mamma è
invece l'altra componente l'altro
ingrediente era quello altamente
culturale filosofico letterario
artistico di mio padre e lasciate ardua
però se avessi preso una via o l'altra
mi sarei sentita in colpa
sostanzialmente perché secondo me avrei
perso un'opportunità
allora ho pensato di fare una cosa di
coltivare questo concetto di dna
meticcio e fare in modo che questi due
elementi questi due ingredienti
diventassero la base funzionale della
mia crescita e del mio sviluppo
personale e professionale e delle ho
iniziato a fare diceva qualcuno qualche
qualche buona penna degli ultimi tempi
scrive oggi si serva molto nella vita no
non si scende in profondità e infatti
quando dovevo scegliere tra fare un
liceo classico il liceo scientifico
indovinate cosa ho scelto il liceo
classico sperimentale bene mia madre era
amareggiata mio padre era
preoccupatissimo non avrei fatto latino
ma avrei fatto un'altra lingua avrei
studiato la chimica ma cosa stai andando
a fare quello che mi avrebbe concesso
poi di crescere sostanzialmente è
infatti aveva un giorno alla fine dei
miei percorsi liceali in cui decido vado
a fare medicina e il giorno successivo
no ho da fare architettura il caos
sembrava regnare sovrano è in realtà
alla fine cosa ho fatto non ho fatto né
l'una nell'altra mi sono iscritta a me a
farmacia e mi che cosa mi è accaduto è
iniziato un evento è iniziato in realtà
l'inizio di un di un innamoramento che è
quello delle persone ho iniziato ad
innamorarmi delle persone a conoscere
osservare le persone in maniera molto
attenta e lì durante uno dei corsi di
specializzazione incontro due di quelle
che saranno stati che sarebbero stati
poi è diventati i miei mentori e conosco
2 cosmetologi e loro accanto a loro
iniziò ad appassionarmi a quest'organo
ma poi succede un altro evento la vita è
zeppa di eventi se vogliamo osservarli
faccio un incontro di questo tipo
incontro un artista contemporaneo
fantastico si chiama a damien hirst è un
artista britannico in quest'opera c'era
chiuso la chiave di volta di quello che
sarebbe stato il mio futuro
professionale
questa sapete cos'è è un bronzo
verniciato enorme è di una collezione
privata
sapete cosa rappresenta rappresenta i
tre millimetri di una sezione
trasversale di pelle ma cosa è riuscito
a fare a rompere quello che è un
atteggiamento scientifico di
osservazione di quest'organo molto
sterile e rendere qualcosa di altamente
pop altamente interessante altamente
emozionante e da qui inizia a ragionare
che non solo amavo osservare le persone
come si muovevano come interagivano con
l'ambiente ma iniziavo ad amare
l'osservazione della loro pelle
quante volte in questo spicchio magari
dopo un applauso c arrossiamo gli zigomi
si arrossano o quante volte di fronte
alla paura la pelle bianca la pelle
racconta un sacco di cose di noi la
pelle racconta quotidianamente quello
che si sta accadendo e da qui nasce
questa domanda provocatoria la pelle che
abito o l'abito pelle è un documento
passivo che ci contiene che ci racchiude
o in realtà è l'organo più funzionale di
relazione che abbiamo con il mondo
esterno credo che questa seconda visione
sia altamente più coerente ed è il
motivo per cui sostanzialmente ci
preoccupiamo di quest'organo forse lo
fanno più le donne lo facevano più le
donne adesso in realtà la percentuale di
uomini che si sono approcciati al mondo
della cura della bellezza della pelle
sta aumentando
ma la cosa
che è cambiata nel mio viaggio culturale
e di competenza di consapevolezza
all'interno del mondo della pelle era
quello di dare valore a lei tutto quello
che iniziano a costruire nei miei
laboratori all'interno della mia
officina cosmetica di ricerca le menti
che coltivavano questo progetto insieme
a me ragionavano per la pelle
l'obiettivo era portare fuori da lei
tutto quello che poteva essere
raccontato
e nei miei percorsi di crescita
professionale mi imbatto poi un'altra
categoria molto importante la
cosmetologa entra in relazione con il
mondo dei dermatologi il mondo dei
dermatologi e un mondo che chi ha
problematiche cutanee conosce bene e sa
l'importanza di entrare in relazione con
questa classe medica ma il mondo dei
dermatologi sapete che cosa racconta ci
dice che la pelle è in realtà un muro
fatto di malta e mattoni sembra un
banale parallelismo in realtà non è così
la i mattoni sono le cellule la malta
sono i lipidi che tengono il sì tema
difensivo cutaneo pronto attivo reattivo
di fronte agli insulti esterne e
immediatamente
mi imbatto nuovamente in un incontro
atipico perché un cosmetologo dovrebbe
studiare la dermatologia
in realtà un cosmetologo avendo questo
dna a meticcio si è trovato di fronte a
che cosa
alla lettura di un'opera o meglio di un
testo fotografico di un fotografo
fantastico irlandese che si chiama simon
watson che ha descritto il racconto di
una casa in una delle vie principali di
dublino
una casa georgiana del xviii secolo e
racconta i muri di questa casa sapete in
che modo lui le definisce muri come
pelle sensibilizzata e quindi il lavoro
del cosmetologo in realtà non è quello
del topo da laboratorio che veste un
camice bianco sterile che in realtà non
è in grado di relazionarsi con il resto
del mondo no il lavoro del cosmetologo
dopo aver guardato questo libro aver
osservato eletto le scritture su questo
libro
è un lavoro che assomiglia fortemente a
quello di un interior designer che cosa
fa un interior designer sfrutta tutte le
competenze che ha per valorizzare al
meglio i muri di una casa per raccontare
la storia di chi ci vive dentro il
cosmetologo può fare esattamente la
stessa cosa
e da qui il cambio netto di osservazione
io non dovevo andare a blindare la pelle
io non dovevo semplicemente andare a
tamponare il disco non four della pelle
io dovevo riuscire a rendere la pelle è
sempre più in grado di comunicare con
l'esterno
e
da questo momento è comparso un mantra
dentro di me che tutti i giorni nei
laboratori di ricerca in cui in cui
lavoro mi dico e ci diciamo
skankers
o skankers la differenza è sottile
normalmente si parla di cura della pelle
ma siete sicuri che in realtà non sia
molto più valorizzante raccontare
prendere consapevolezza
che la pelle si preoccupa di noi ci
protegge ci difende ma
contemporaneamente comunica verso
l'esterno
ma pensavo di avere raggiunto il massimo
dell'espressione della originalità della
mia professione e accade un fatto
a cadevo fatto meraviglioso divento
mamma
nasce penelope e penelope è riuscita
contatto a dimostrare un concetto
fortemente disruptive sapete qual è che
in realtà attraverso la pelle attraverso
il contatto pelle a pelle attraverso un
abbraccio noi riusciamo a raccontarci
un'infinità di emozioni
un'infinità di sensazioni riusciamo a
raccontarci la paura la gioia riusciamo
a generare un numero di informazioni
molto maggiori rispetto a quelle che
potremmo veicolare attraverso delle
parole una accanto all'altra e quindi
sostanzialmente il messaggio che vi
voglio lasciare è un messaggio molto
semplice
preoccupatevi di quest'organo
occupatevene con cura
scegliete in maniera molto accorta
quello che andate ad applicarci potrebbe
essere un prodotto cosmetico potrebbe
essere un capo di abbigliamento e fatelo
perché senza di lei
voi non ci sareste io non ci sarei
chiedete a un grandi ustionato come sta
senza avere l'organo pelle bello integro
e bello compatto e poi dovete
preoccuparvi né
sostanzialmente per un altro motivo
perché in realtà è l'abito è l'unico
abito che indosserete per tutta la vita
[Applauso]